in
in greek civilization
around 400 hbc
and uh maybe to 200 hbc
the uh development by people like plato
and then by people like euclid
and in a sense
what
they thought about
was
how do you take
this very practical mathematics that we
do and how do you make it something
how do you really talk about the
abstraction that's involved in that
mathematics
so it's one thing to say that these
specific numbers and you do this and you
do that but there's this kind of idea of
numbers abstractly or triangles
abstractly not this particular triangle
that's used to you know the layout of
this field and so on and one of the
things that came about was which was
particularly prominent in euclid um
euclid was a
mathematician who worked in alexandria
at the library of alexandria kind of the
an early version of a university in in
egypt um
in uh
maybe 150 bc-ish time frame essentially
nothing is known about his life um only
his works survived his works were the
second most published book in history
for a long time
uh
the uh
after only the the christian bible
the um
so the thing that um uh what was in
euclid's books
well
what it is
is
a way of talking about geometry
that
is in a sense abstracted
it says for example consider the concept
of a point consider the concept of a
line
consider
lines that are parallel
what what implication does it have if
you say that lines are parallel and then
this is true and then that's true how do
you infer kind of logically some result
and in euclid the uh you go through he
has kind of uh about 10 axioms at the
beginning of things that he claims he's
going to use as part of his system of
logical deduction
and there's uh the very first
common notion of euclid is a point is
something which has no part a point is
something indivisible there is a notion
of a geometrical point there's a way of
just having a point in space
and having it be the case that that is
just one place and that has nothing
inside it and then the second statement
is a line is something which goes
between two points and
then it builds up from there and it
builds up in euclid's actual works it's
got about 460
uh results that come out of those those
axioms at the beginning
and the the very uh the final and most
difficult to derive result is the result
that there are five platonic solids that
there are only five sub figures
that where all the faces and and uh
and corners are the same uh just the
tetrahedron the cube the uh
octahedron the dodecahedron and the
icosahedron the fact that in
three-dimensional space those are the
only
regular solids um that is the sort of
the the pinnacle of achievement in
euclid's books and he derives that on
the basis of these uh purely in a sense
logically on the basis of these uh
fundamental kind of propositions that he
asserts
about space
i think what he thought was
that those were mere
uh crispenings condensations
of things that everybody sort of knew
what's true like uh two parallel lines
never cross
that's one of the one of that's the
fifth postulate of euclid is that if you
have parallel lines they just stay
parallel they never can cross over
and he just took that as being a kind of
a precise statement of something that
was obviously true about the world that
was something that was a just a fact
about geometry i don't think he really
understood the extent to which that fact
might depend on the physics of the world
to what extent there was a feature of
human thinking about the world he didn't
really
tease apart those kinds of things but to
him what he was doing was he was writing
down a kind of an axiomatic system that
would describe in precise terms the
world as he thought the world was
and then on the basis of that axiomatic
system he was able to make purely
logical deductions in other words
there was sort of a distinction made
between things that were merely a matter
of opinion oh this might follow from
that and somebody might disagree about
this and so on versus things which were
just a matter of in a sense precise uh
deduction that you didn't have to
say you know you might say you know all
sheep are white or something well
actually there's a black sheep somewhere
and it might be wrong but once you have
these these logical in sense these these
formal axioms of euclid once you say
those are true there's a whole bunch of
other stuff you can deduce
and the deduction of that other stuff
does not depend doesn't have the
possibility of saying oh whoops it
turned out there was a black sheep it's
something which can be as a pure
abstract matter as a nessa as a feature
of sort of abstract necessity those
things will follow given the assumptions
that were put in at the beginning the
axioms that were put in the beginning
euclid i think believed that those
axioms were
kind of a a matter of a description of
the world that was sort of an obvious
feature of the world
now you know a lot happened um
uh
in after that time after euclid kind of
defined this kind of axiomatic abstract
way to deduce things about mathematics
that was something that was a kind of a
highlight
of kind of abstract thinking for a
couple of thousand years
and it was used as an example endlessly
by philosophers and so on to distinguish
things which are just kind of happened
to be true about the world
that uh you know it might it might
happen to be true about the world that
we have five fingers it was because the
critters who had you know six-fold
symmetry or something back in the
pre-cambrian period happened to die out
because of this
you know thing
you know some accident it's just a a
contingent
a thing that happens to be true about
the world or so we might think we don't
know for sure something like that it's
very hard to know for sure what is just
happens to be that way versus what has
to be that way i mean a notable feature
in modern times is it always used to be
the case when i was a kid that a a
classic example of a contingent fact
about the world is that there are nine
planets in our solar system there were
nine then because pluto still counted as
a planet but the fact that the our solar
system happens to have eight planets
nine planets whatever is was viewed as
being something which was just it
happens to be that way in the world as
the world happens to be
rather than that is something that we
could derive as a matter of of uh
abstract necessity now that we know i
don't know what there's 5 000 planets
around um
around many different stars
we know that our solar system
is the the structure of our solar system
is something which well it's actually a
little bit unusual but it's
fundamentally a derivable thing given
that you have a star of our side of the
size of the sun etc etc etc you can more
or less say they're going to be about
nine planets now they're details about
well maybe there were planets that
collided with each other maybe there's
weird things about jupiter and saturn
being comparable in size and that
leading to inner planets that didn't
collide with each other and et cetera et
cetera et cetera lots of details but
fundamentally it no longer looks like a
random fact about the world it looks
like something which is conceivably
derivable
so exactly where those boundaries are
isn't isn't completely clear but at
least at the time of euclid i think he
thought of himself as taking what was in
a sense obvious from human senses and
crisping it up to make something which
could have deductions done from it which
would be then true about the world
because the underlying stuff was kind of
obviously true about the world
well
what developed in mathematics in the uh
following couple of thousand years
there was a lot of uh
practical development of well
mathematical notation was a big thing
about 400 years ago
that sort of launched what became
algebra later calculus and so on there
got to be much more sophistication in
the kinds of ways that one did
mathematics when euclid was doing it he
was using words only um and the people
then added pictures of geometrical
diagrams and later on people filled in
proofs that were sort of standardized
forms of the proofs for euclid although
himself just said here's a statement
here's another statement here's another
statement
rather than himself giving the proofs
so
then
the thing that happened in the 1800s
was that
a lot of things that people sort of
thought were self-evidently true
were people started questioning them
like do parallel lines never cross
there was a big thing a chap called
lubachewski was the big one
for for pointing this out that well
actually if you have a curved surface
like on the surface of the earth you
draw two parallel lines they actually
can can cross over um and uh the um
depends on on how you draw them so to
speak um uh the uh sort of a famous
example would be
um
two
lines that um you might draw
at uh 90 degrees to each other one going
around the equator one going around
meridian around the earth those lines
will certainly cross over um even though
if you drew them in the plane for
example two lines which are at 90
degrees they'll just go out forever
um
and uh so it in a curved space
that uh isn't true anymore that parallel
lines will never cross
um and the real question was
to first of all have the idea that
mathematically abstractly we can imagine
a curved space
it then took until 1915 or so when
einstein sort of pointed out actually
actual physical space is curved and so
parallel lines parallel beams of light
for example
which
light follows kind of the the shortest
paths
those parallel lines can cross and for
example if you have two beams of light
going around on opposite sides of a star
or a black hole or whatever those those
beams of light can be gravitational
lensing it's it's called those beams of
light will be gradually uh
pulled together and it will eventually
cross
and so it is neither true in principle
that parallel lines can never cross you
can imagine a curved version of space in
which they cross and moreover it turns
out that our actual physical space of
the universe in which we live has the
property that it can have curved parts
where in a sense parallel parallel lines
drawn in in physical form
can cross over and so what happened in
the in the 18 early 1800s 1830s and so
on there were a series of things like
that there was labor chewski and
parallel lines and curved space there
was gawa theory the theory of groups
where one had things where one had been
thinking about things like
numbers x and y and you would say x
times y is equal to y times x well
actually if x and y represent things
that are sort of generalizations of
numbers it might not be true that x
times y is equal to y times x that came
up in group theory it came up in the
theory of quaternions
um it uh that was again a place where
one sort of generalizing the notion of
arithmetic came up in boolean algebra uh
from george boole in 1830s or so
um the uh
where there was kind of a formulation of
logic where it was ands and oars are
like roughly like pluses and timezes but
they're not quite like pluses and times
is they're kind of a generalization of
that and so what came into existence was
this idea that you could sort of just
write down an arbitrary axiom system for
the world and
then you could or you could write down
an arbitrary axiom system and then you
deduce things on the basis of that axiom
system
and that in a sense through the period
of the 1800s that became viewed as
kind of the
what was mathematics
mathematics was in the time of euclid
mathematics have been it's really about
the way the world is and our perceptions
of the world and kind of a crispening up
of that and the ability to make sort of
deductions on the basis of that but by
the 1800s it was more just put down
whatever axioms you want and then we can
deduce things from it in a sense the
content of mathematics started to be
about this process
of deducing things from axioms where the
axioms came from that was kind of
arbitrary but the deduction from the
axioms was the stuff of mathematics
so it didn't matter so the question of
was what you were getting out
fundamentally true
well not really it just was a crap
matter that the deduction from the
axioms could be fundamentally true but
the axioms themselves it might be the
case that you had a positively curved
space a negatively curved space you
might have x y equals minus y x you
might have this you might have that it
was sort of arbitrary what those axioms
were but then you could build this whole
tower on top of those
and this kind of came to a head in the
late 1800s the beginning of the 1900s
when people started imagining that
really mathematics should be built
it was sort of this arbitrary structure
built on top of whatever axioms you
chose and famously a chap called david
hilbert who was a famous mathematician
around the beginning of the 1900s
was like actually mathematics could be
about
tables and chairs and beer bottles as
much as it could be about lines and
points and planes
and that the kind of the statements of
mathematics were purely abstract
structural statements completely
independent of the stuff that they were
talking about and a thing that we would
consider to be
a a thing that we can have sensory data
about because we can we can have the
idea that we think we know what space is
we move around in it there's certain
distances in it we have a
as humans we have a definite sensory
opinion of space but the idea of hilbert
was mathematics is really not about that
mathematics is about this pure abstract
structure
and so that meant that mathematics was
in a sense something that was mechanized
mechanizable once you had it as a pure
abstract structure like that you could
just say i'm going to take what euclid
did and i'm going to make it something
where i can essentially have a machine
that will go through and deduce all the
true statements based on the axioms that
for example euclid had written down now
at the time that euclid were that
hilbert was doing this at 1900 or so
computers didn't exist there were
mechanical calculators that did
arithmetic and so on but the idea of
electronic computers and so on was still
a solid 40-something years in the future
and the idea of computation as an
abstract thing just as in the early days
of of the creation of mathematics people
had abstracted the idea of numbers away
from numbers of goats and so on people
by the 1930s were abstracting
computation away from the specifics of
which computation are you doing the
notion of computation in the abstract so
to speak and that was what alan turing
and people like that
did in in developing kind of this
abstract notion of computation
so the question
that uh
uh i should say by the way that this
this idea of mechanization
that hilbert had
uh he particularly was interested in
doing it for euclid the interesting
thing is we finally more or less done
that in wolverine language recently
we've been building kind of the ability
to reason about geometry and to
represent kind of geometrical facts
as symbolic statements that can be
mechanically handled that's something
finally in 2021 2022
is something that we are achieving uh
that the com the computationalization of
what euclid did a couple of thousand
years ago but anyway when when hilbert
had this idea of let's just take the
axioms and mathematics and mechanically
deduce everything that's true from them
the the big kind of uh
the very bad uh thing from that point of
view that happened was in 1931 kurt
godel
proved this thing called girl's theorem
which said actually there will be things
that you can write down
that seem like their statements about
arithmetic things like this particular
kind of equation you know x cubed plus y
cubed equals z to the fourth minus seven
or something the you know you have an
equation like that
and the question is can you prove that
that equation doesn't have any solutions
let's say for integer values of x y and
z for whole numbers x y and z
and that what he showed is that there
are statements that are as
sort of arithmetic like as that
but which the axioms that people had
written down the so-called piano axioms
for arithmetic simply couldn't reach
those statements it couldn't tell you
whether those statements were true or
not
the the the the sort of the axiomatic
system just there were in a sense if you
were going to make a proof of that the
proof might be infinitely long it might
not be possible to have any finite proof
of that statement
and so that was something goodle
established in 1931 and that very
quickly made people say oh this pure
mechanization of mathematics is not
going to work now the effort to have
started that mechanization was what led
to the idea of computation and led to
everything we have today and software in
the whole sort of computational paradigm
that we have today came out of
essentially a failed attempt to
understand kind of the the foundations
of mathematics and what mathematics
really was
but if you ask a typical working
mathematician today what what is
mathematics what is it what what
what what is it built on what what what
what kind of a thing is it
many would probably still say
well ultimately you can kind of dig down
underneath all the mathematics we're
doing
and it's certain axioms
and the usual ones that they'll quote
are the zomero franco
zfc axioms of set theory which are
extremely obscure and obstructs things
that are very much not very close
to any kind of human uh
kind of intuition about what's going on
because they talk about sets
a set is just a collection of things are
set as sort of like numbers being an
abstraction
of numbers of goats numbers of sheep
a set is an abstraction of just a
collection of things they could be sheep
they could be goats they could be
numbers they could be lots of other
things
but then
the kind of um
uh thing that
one is interest that one starts to talk
about is well what happens if you have
an infinite set like for example the set
of all integers or the set of all real
numbers
what can you do with those infinite sets
what's true about what happens when you
combine two infinite sets how do you can
you always pick uh
things out of both sets and and how does
that all work
those become the axioms of set theory
and they are not very human
intuitionally
connected they're things that are quite
abstruse pieces of mathematics
and in principle the edifice of
mathematics that exists today about
three or four million theorems
uh people write down in the literature
of mathematics have been published over
the over the centuries most of them very
recently because things are you know
there are more and more math there are
many more mathematicians alive today
than have ever lived in the past um so
you know it's it's an expanding kind of
area but the question then is what
really is it what are the things that
one is building um how does uh is it
really built from the zfc axioms of set
theory is that really what
mathematicians think they're doing it's
not what mathematicians mostly think
they're doing
but there is always this kind of um
thing where in principle we could drill
down and we could find what we are
rooted with our foundations are on top
of set theory so people might say it
isn't probably true
because in actuality what mathematicians
will do
is they try and establish things that
they think are true in some sense
but they will do it using things that
they kind of assume are true
and just like euclid assumed that
parallel lines could never cross
there are things that mathematicians
implicitly or explicitly assume are true
on the basis of kind of their intuition
and kind of the collective uh beliefs of
mathematicians over the ages
and those are the things from which
mathematicians try to develop proofs
of results today which are perhaps the
results that they might prove
maybe things very far away from things
about which we have intuition
but the proofs end up being things that
go back to things that seem like they're
true and that's kind of the practical
definition of of proofs in mathematics
is you're making some kind of narrative
explanation of why something is true
using these often fairly precise methods
to say okay this is true based on
what um
what was uh uh what we think is true
down here now people sometimes say but
in principle we can drill all the way
down and get to the underlying axioms of
set theory but in practice people don't
do that there's been an effort to kind
of formalize mathematics
to use particularly proof assistant
programs where you as a mathematician
are saying i'm going to try and start
from these foundations and i'm going to
fill in puzzle pieces to get to some
result that i want
but it's a very arduous time-consuming
thing to do that
and it's something where
there it is the big surprise one of the
big surprises is
you can actually change the foundations
a lot
and not change many of the results which
are deduced
so for example some fact some some
theorem the pythagorean theorem the fact
that the sum of the x squared plus y
squared equals z squared for the for the
um uh edges of a right angle triangle
that's something where you could get
incredibly pedantic and persnickety and
say well what exactly do you mean by the
length you know that's defined by a real
number with an infinite number of digits
and you've got this kind of thing going
on with that and what do you mean by
equality what happens if the infinite
fifth digit is different et cetera et
cetera said you could get very
persnickety about it but it turns out
the theorem is true for many different
versions of that persnickety-ness
so in a sense it's a more robust general
statement about
something related to mathematics
than uh than it is about these axiom
systems and i've sort of realized
recently i mean i've kind of changed my
mind about how this works because i've
been working on meta mathematics and the
the question of sort of what is the
structure of this thing that we're
creating from axioms we can make proofs
of theorems any given theorem might have
many different proofs what's the role of
those different proofs how do you get
from one proof to another proof you know
what what kind of a thing is that and so
on how do you think about those kinds of
things and and how what in the end is
this thing that mathematicians do that
they call mathematics
that is somehow you can
how does it relate to these sort of
axiom systems you can write down
and what i've sort of realized is that
the the mathematics that people do is
very humanized mathematics they're
thinking about concepts that humans care
about and can think about at some level
you can drill down
uh sort of below that level two things
where you're looking at the individual
axioms and everything that's happening
there you get this kind of machine code
version that's very incomprehensible to
humans
and you can actually drill even further
down than that i've realized um to
something even lower level
but it's not but the thing that people
humans view as being the stuff of
mathematics is something at a much
higher level it's kind of like when you
do
uh when you study physics
if you have a flow of a fluid like water
or something that's at a sort of human
scale and you can see various features
and you might see a vortex things like
this but down underneath there are a
bunch of molecules bouncing around
and so it is i think with mathematics
that the mathematics the mathematicians
deal with is more at the level of kind
of things like vortices it's more at
this kind of large human scale whereas
sort of underneath that are sort of the
micro details the machine code you can
go to the axioms you can go even below
the axioms
i think the thing that is kind of the
the ultimate object sort of below the
axioms is the thing i call the ruliad
and the ruliad is the following thing so
imagine all possible rules
for doing computations all possible
rules by which you might take some array
of black and white squares you might
have some rule that says what happens to
each black and white square you might
have some network which is defined by
certain relations you might say what
happens when these relations are
combined these are all rules for doing
different kinds of things let's just
imagine that you could just
get all of the possible rules for things
all possible definite rules for things
all possible things about which you
could have definite rules and let's say
you just run those rules and you run
them for an infinite number of steps
what you have there is this thing i call
the ruliad which is the sort of
entangled limit
of running all possible computations for
an infinite number of steps
so you might say well how could that
possibly be anything other than just a
complete mess
but the thing is it has a very definite
structure because you can have two
computations they start in two different
places they end up producing an
equivalent result that produces some
kind of structure in this ruliad you can
keep going and you've got different
uh kinds of um structure produced when
things branch et cetera et cetera et
cetera so in the end this this ruliad
structure
which is the entangled limit of all
possible computations so it's not like
i'm picking these computations and not
those ones it's like you take all
possible computations and there might be
different ways to represent those
computations you take all possible ones
that ends up being this object that i
call the ruliad
and one feature of the ruliad is there's
only one of it
and
you
are
basically it is a necessary object as
necessary as given the definition of one
plus one that it's equal to two it is
similarly necessary there's nothing
about it that is oh it happens to be
that way it doesn't happen anything it
is necessarily has the structure it has
and so
one of the things that is sort of a big
realization of the last year or so for
me
is
that
uh sort of everything we experience in
both physics and mathematics
is kind of a sampling of the rouliad
that the physical world
is actually what's what's what's
ultimately real is the ruliad and we are
basically as observers of small pieces
of the ruliad we get to observe those
small pieces
and we kind of name p the aspects of the
ruliad things like space and time and
electrons and things like this
but those are our particular way of
sampling the rouhiad gives us
these particular features of our world
the one that we perceive physically and
an important aspect of this is the
notion of time which is kind of this
progression of these computations in the
rouliad or the notion of space
this idea that it's there's a certain
amount of uniformity in the ruliad so
you can essentially take you and your
sort of uh sensing of the ruliada move
it to somewhere else and that's possible
to do without you getting shredded to
pieces that you can that motion is
possible that even though
as we move around we might be made from
different kind of atoms of space
that still there is an identity to us
that we can carry around as we move
around and that's kind of the the notion
that there is a thing like space and
that's another feature of the ruliad is
that there can be a thing like space
there can be a thing like time there can
be a thing like space the way we
particular
we as sort of observers of the rouley ad
sample the ruliab with our particular
senses and our particular kind of
capabilities of our brains and so on
we sample it in such a way that this is
what we perceive about the world that it
has space and time and the other
features of physics as we perceive them
well the thing that is part of the
sort of fairly recent realization is
that mathematics is also just the ruliad
and our experience of mathematics is
based on sampling the ruliad in certain
ways and you can certainly sample it to
correspond to what will be the
consequence of this particular axiom
system but the ruliad has sort of all
possible axiom systems in it so in a
sense your decision to sample this
particular axiom system is a decision on
the part of the observer and what's a
little bit confusing is that there's
actually a level below the level of
axiom systems the raw computation on
which the axiom systems are based is
this sort of raw ruliad level the level
of pure raw computation so you might ask
well what are the things that that raw
computation uh is dealing with in the
case of physics
we think that raw computation we can
identify the things it's dealing with
and they're the atoms of space the
elements of what make up the structure
of space and the structure of everything
in our universe in mathematics what is
below axioms what do you make those
axioms out of when you have some some
variable in the axiom system what is
that ultimately computationally made out
of what does it sort of compile down to
and there's this kind of notion of the
thing calling eems eme s
that are the the fundamental elements
the lowest level elements the the kind
of atoms of existence
the the things that are the the lowest
elements from which you can make
mathematics you can make physics where
the eams are identified with the atoms
of space and so on one of the
consequences of this view
is that
in some sense physics and mathematics
are built on the same thing they're both
built on the ruliad and they are in a
sense they are the same thing in some
sense
they are simply being observed in
different ways you get physics you get
mathematics
another consequence that has
is remember i was talking about euclid
having this view that mathematics
is something which is a crisping up of
common human experience
well now we've got a picture where in a
sense mathematics is an extraction from
the rouliad made by human experience
just as physics is an extraction from a
rouliad made by human experience and the
question is and that that then gives one
the idea that mathematics has a reality
to it just like physics has a reality to
it that is something extracted by our
human experience
and so for example kurt godel when he
proved girdle's theorem in 1931 one of
the things he was trying to do was to
show that axiom systems weren't the full
story that in fact one could have a
direct notion of truth in mathematics
and the raxiom systems were just kind of
a distraction
i have long
assumed that that isn't systems were not
a distraction were the the real thing
that was the underlying structure of
mathematics but i've recently kind of
come to the conclusion that's just not
right and that girdle was more correct
in believing that there's sort of a
reality underneath mathematics that is
something
very similar to the reality of physics
and in a sense as soon as we say that
the physical universe exists which is
kind of a very basic statement to make
about the world the universe exists it's
not just that we have a pure
consciousness you know we're thinking
about things and there really isn't an
outside universe
as soon as we have the idea that it's
worth saying the universe exists then it
will be a necessary thing to say that
similarly mathematics exists this kind
of an idea often attributed to plato
kind of platonic notion of ideal forms
as a kind of a thing in the world
distinct from kind of the outside world
or our internal experiences and so on
this kind of world of ideal forms that
were somehow some kind of abstraction of
those things well but that was somehow
real in some sense well this whole
argument about the roulette and physics
and mathematics being the same and so on
is very much in that direction of saying
that there is a real thing underneath
mathematics and so on so this is kind of
a a what
is the thing of mathematics i i find it
amusing that um
uh there's
people sometimes um
for some reason there's an intersection
between interest in kind of ma
blockchain
and um kind of the the notion of uh
uh sort of and blockchain it's kind of
like computation is going to run the
world
which is undoubtedly the case
and
that in a sense computation you might
think has its foundations in mathematics
and uh so that these kinds of axiom
systems and mathematics and so on will
ultimately flow through to being the
determining uh kinds of uh things that
will sort of specify how the blockchain
that runs the world kind of thing works
i don't think that's quite right because
i think that the real story is that
computation is a more general kind of
thing than mathematics and these axiom
systems for mathematics were chosen with
some arbitrariness and one might even
say that one of the sort of concepts of
the whole blockchain world is how much
it's possible to sort of factor out the
notion of governance and governments and
countries and things like that from the
whole picture of the way the world is
run
that sort of code is running the world
so to speak as opposed to
something that is some kind of human
enforced rule of law and so on i'm not
saying that's a good idea but that's
kind of a the concept of of sort of the
the the philosophical the political
philosophy of blockchain is is for many
people is something of that kind
and so it then becomes something of an
irony if you say well you know we really
believe below all this blockchain layer
of computation and so on and so on and
so on it's all eventually going to be
based on mathematics
well and then the mathematics is all
well it's all based on the zfc axioms of
set theory let's say
well that's that's not really cr that's
really kind of can't can't
it's not the right thing it's it's uh
it's sort of interesting though if one
takes the point of view that it's that
one's factoring out kind of the
governance
of um
uh of the um
of sort of the world
into these sort of lumps of computation
but you say but they are going to be
rooted in something we know is true the
cfc axioms of set theory well that's not
really right
because those are a human construct and
they're actually a human concept doesn't
even capture what we want to do in
mathematics
there are things that are undoubtedly
assumed to be true by mathematicians
which are not captured by the axioms of
zfc's that theory
and that that so it's kind of a the
concept that there's sort of a a below
everything all the mathematics is solid
even if we don't know what the
constitution of the world should be for
the ais and so on even if we might argue
about that well at least there's a layer
of things
which is mathematics which is undeniable
well that's just not true
the the you can absolutely write down an
axiom system and try and work out its
consequences at least until you get
bitten by girdles theorem but the um the
idea that there is a sort of a and
you know
as as to quote um you know something
which is sort of referring to um sort of
truths to be self-evident so to speak
you know that is this idea of sort of
the necessary truth
and you know when one tries to you know
like in a constitution or something one
says you know they hold these truths to
be self-evident which is by the way an
interesting construction because to hold
these truths to be self-evident is
different from saying the truths are
necessary truths
and so in a sense that's like setting up
an axiomatic structure like euclid we
hold these truths to be self-evident
then we're going to build this whole
structure on the basis of that
is kind of a euclidean kind of
construction at that level and an
interesting one and a good way to
formulate that way of thinking about
things but i think that the
the thing to realize is that when you
and anything you might say there
is there is no
there is no ultimate
this is how it is and there's nothing
else no other way it could be one of the
features of this idea of the rouliad is
that all possible rules are there all
possible crazy things
that
can happen in the universe are there but
the fascinating thing which is a matter
of essentially mathematical analysis to
show that it's the case that for an
observer like us
we necessarily perceive things like
space and time and gravity and so on and
that's a consequence of us observers
like us
with our kinds of sensory capabilities
and so on will necessarily perceive in
this in this giant mass of all possible
rules that is the ruliad we will
perceive these particular features of
slices of the ruliad and you know our
friendly aliens for example might
perceive something utterly and
incoherently different
and you know that's an issue for us in
terms of like you know hello aliens
it's like they may be separated both in
physical space and what i call rulial
space
in this kind of how do they slice
through iliad is there slice something
where they say i don't care about space
and time i care about these other
concepts that reflect some precise
detail of how the atoms of space
interact in this way in that way and
we're like we don't care about that
that's something way down
you know 10 to the minus 100 meters in
size trillions of trillions and
trillions of times smaller than anything
we can sense we don't care about that we
care about whether you can
you know walk across the room and they
say what do you mean what what's the
structure that's walking across the room
we don't see a structure there all we
see is a bunch of configurations of
atoms of space that have this or that
feature and we really care about those
things we don't care about the fact that
the atoms of space are arranged to make
the matter to make the physical atoms
and the matter and so on that makes you
that seems like an irrelevant thing to
us what we care about is these sort of
micro details of the motion of atoms of
space for example and so that this uh
the idea of this kind of notion of the
ruliad is that there isn't
there is a a an abstract necessity but
it's an abstract necessity that contains
everything but there is a contingent
fact about that that is the way in which
we sample it we as humans who've evolved
in the way we have and have learnt
things the way we've learned things we
sample it in this way and so that's what
we perceive about the rouley ad now of
course you can say well what's going to
happen in the future are we going to
sample things differently and the answer
is yes
as our technology evolves as our ways of
thinking about things evolve we will
gradually move in real space just like
we're sending out spacecraft and
physical space we are in a sense by the
developments we make in science and in
intellectual issues we're gradually
moving in rule space and we're able to
see sort of more of this rouliad that is
the underlying thing that represents
everything the ruling out is very big
um it's uh maybe um
oh i don't know i had some estimates of
10 to the 10 to the 350. um so that's a
that's a um uh let's see it's a it's a
one with 350 zeros after it and then
it's that number of zeros after a one
um
roughly i mean that estimate is probably
not exactly right but that's the kind of
that gives you a sense of everything
that there is at least to this moment in
the existence of our universe so to
speak
and uh so you know we represent just
like we might think we're kind of small
because we represent only this uh you
know these these critters that are on
planet number three of this uh solar
system on the and the somewhat outer
reaches of this rather typical spiral
galaxy in this rather typical cluster of
galaxies
in this you know in the universe so to
speak that we are at that level of
smallness relative to the universe and
at that level of kind of arbitrariness
with respect to the universe it gets
there's there's much further down by the
time you're looking at this whole
roulette of possible rules and so on it
is much much bigger than the physical
universe the physical universe is but
one tiny slice of that whole ruling out
of possibilities and that's kind of a uh
it's it's something that's sort of
interesting to think about but in a
sense the slice we're on
is the slice that is a representation of
who we are so to speak and it's not the
case that in some sense that slice is
arbitrary
but in some sense it may be less
arbitrary than saying we happen to be on
this particular planet in this
particular solar system this particular
galaxy and so on it might be a little
less arbitrary than that given the way
we are so to speak there is a there's
kind of that determines which slice of
the roulette we're on now you could also
argue that we are the way we are because
well gosh you know our night sky isn't
bright at night we're not near the
center of a galaxy with tons of stars in
the sky we're not this and that and the
other we're not
uh you know you could make a lot of
arguments about about that
well anyway that was a long description
of um uh of a little bit about sort of
the the way of thinking about
mathematics that i at least have have
evolved in recent times and i'm just in
the process of writing this giant thing
about this
um
there's a question here from
wwe um
asking in what ways
am i better than an ai
um
well
you know
we have to kind of define what we mean
by better
um
and uh
the um
uh
i think i would say the following thing
any i've been kind of wondering you know
i i i store a lot of stuff that i do so
i store every keystroke i type you know
i do these live streams
there's a lot of me out there that is
recorded
and the question is could you take all
that
stuff recorded about me and make a bot
that is me or a better me from all that
information
in other words the information that i'm
recording is not a small fraction of all
my sensory experiences at this point
it's a decently large fraction of them
and given that could one use that to
essentially build a better me that is a
pure ai
and the answer is i suspect for so it's
not we're not quite there yet but for
some purposes yes
on the other hand there is
a notion and this is generally true
about ai ai in some sense is an
automation process it's a take what we
knew we wanted to do and figure out how
to do it automatically the issue is what
do we want to do and that's something
where
i don't think there's just like we're
talking about mathematics and and
its foundations and there's no necessary
foundation of mathematics there's no
necessary constitution for the way
things should be in the world there's no
necessary set of goals
for everybody should want to do this
it's it's something where in a sense
that's the that's the main thing that we
humans sort of have over the concept of
the ais is the what do we want to do
type question
and
that's something which is sort of a a
feature of our history and lots of other
aspects but that's something that sort
of the initiative so to speak
is something that
um
is an arbitrary thing chosen by us now
we could certainly make an ai that will
imitate
the creation of of that initiative and
in a sense from the outside you might be
able to see no difference between those
things but from the inside it feels like
we are trying to get things we have
certain goals that we've developed and
this is a different thing from from what
we would be seeing in an ai we could
have the ai will have no
unless we give it some some goal as a
principle for making goals it does not
have an intrinsic way to make goals
so i think that's um
that's one thing i think as a practical
matter today
um i'm perhaps
either proud or sorry to say that i
think i do a lot of things that are not
readily doable by an ai
um i think
you know an interesting question is i i
write lots of words language code uh
like write lots of computational
language
and uh is that something an ai could do
well the answer is no not really uh
because it is an expression of things
coming out of my mind right now it is
something where i'm trying to go and the
goal of language design is to go as
directly as possible from the way i
think about things to a representation
in computational language and i just
don't think that that's that's something
which almost by definition is not
ai-able in the current state of in in
that sense
uh
let's see there's a question here about
um saying uh
um
javascript will run out of milliseconds
from aaron
in 270 thousand years i didn't know that
specifically it doesn't surprise me
have i ever written code that created a
date object past that time
how far in the future could work
language represent
uh i don't know actually i i think our
data objects
can have arbitrary length numbers in
them so in a sense you can probably
represent i'm sure you can represent
much further in the future
than the universe has existed so far in
the past which is you know 14 point
something billion years i'm sure you can
represent uh hundreds of billions of
years into the future and beyond that
i think that
there's a question of what can you say
about times like that
one question is about for example
astronomical computations i know that
our ephemerides those are the things
that let you compute you know positions
of planets and so on uh we currently
have ephemerides that go for a couple
hundred years i think we're about to
extend them to ones that go for a few
thousand years um but there's a lot of
data to specify the precise positions of
planets over that period of time and if
you get beyond a few thousand years it's
very hard to have accurate data because
it will matter you know what random
perturbation from this place or what
random interstellar asteroid comes
through the solar system and perturbs
this thing these are things that we
don't know and we can't sort of uh
formally compute so to speak
so those are um
uh
it's some uh that that's um
um
uh
but now in terms of
how far you know i have various kinds of
systems that send mail and do things at
certain times in the future i i always
used to have a program called fmail that
i had created oh 30 years ago now that
but uh uh
sent mail in the future and i it's a
good question how far out the longest
fmail programs
are
in um that ff mail specifications are
that i created i don't know 30 years ago
or something i don't know i haven't
it's
it's always one of these practical
things that you create a system like
that
and then there's a question of how
uh
you know does it keep working long
enough that when it's going to send a
message 20 years in the future uh you
know do you get it is it how does that
work i have long wondered about the
creation of a digital time safe
something where for example you could
say i'm gonna encrypt this thing and in
a hundred years it's gonna decrypt
itself and tell the world about it
and i've wondered how to do that and i
have to have a think about it again
because with modern
blockchain technology there might now be
a way the last time i thought about it
there really wasn't a good way to do
that there wasn't a thing that will
deterministically happen in 100 years
and um
i mean one could do things where one
says you know when the planets line up
this way then this will happen
uh kind of reminds me of the the movie
2001 space odyssey it came out 50
50 something years ago that had this
idea of you know the aliens leave this
uh
beacon on the moon
and its way of knowing whether there's
intelligent life on earth so to speak is
does it ever see the light of the sun
because it's been buried and if somebody
excavates it and it sees the light of
the sun then something
something happened something
some there was some
event that was significant now of course
in reality you know there might have
been some some meteorite impact that um
uh exposed this thing to to the sun and
that would have been a a false positive
a false signal for it um you know it's
just a movie not not reality so to speak
but there's sort of a question of could
you
uh
could you have something which in some
kind of reminds one of the druids and
stonehenge and all that kind of thing
when the planets line up in just such a
way then things open up and you know the
the the mysterious kind of secret uh uh
chamber opens up and and the secrets of
the past are revealed
uh it's something where
people from time to time will have these
time capsules where people will will um
uh
um
[Music]
store them in the foundations of
buildings recently i i guess there have
been some that have been found that were
stored in the foundations of statues and
so on
um
it's uh
the um i think that the um
uh this idea of you know we'll put a
time capsule somewhere and people will
find it a long time in the future i know
in in
times of the babylonians and things like
that
um
people would uh put in the foundations
of temples that they built and things
like this
things that said you know were messages
to their enemies saying if you're seeing
this you're cursed
in other words if you destroyed this
building that have been built and you've
gotten down to the foundation stone
then uh you know just
you know know that
you know you're cursed so to speak and
that was kind of a um
uh a thing there but in a
more recent times people have kind of
buried these um uh time capsules of
various kinds i'm afraid the history i i
had a little look a couple years ago
about sort of what had happened to time
capsules from the past and it's a sad
story people usually forget they buried
them and then when they open them up
what what's there isn't that exciting
anyway
and uh it's all stuff where we know the
history and it wasn't something very
surprising but it's sort of an
interesting question can you make a
digital time safe where you store
information that will be for example
encrypted until some particular time in
the future when it could be decrypted i
mean in a sense the the proof of work
concept
um
of of uh of blockchain is a little bit
like this idea of you do a lot of
computation to get to a point
but again i have not been figure able to
figure out sort of a protocol where you
can have something which is encrypted
until a lot of stuff has happened and
then it will automatically decrypt
itself
it's um
let's see
um
the question here
from hamid
is it possible to have a civilization
purely based on biological technology
for example building microscopes
airplanes etc out of organic materials
and by growing them somehow
you know
people used to say
i remember people saying this in the
early 1980s
and 1970s and so on people who like to
be contrarians
saying oh this electronic stuff it's
just a fad
really in the future everything will be
growing biologically
well
what i think is true
is that biology is our one example of
molecular scale computation
and there will be more
molecular scale computation will be a
thing
and right now we say
you know we make something that's made
of plastic it's made of metal it's made
of whatever else it's made of some
material and then we say we can build a
computer out of a material i think in
the future we will be able to say
everything is made of computers
it's you know down at the molecular
scale everything we're dealing with will
be a programmable thing just like the
components of a computer are today so in
that sense
this idea from biology and molecular
scale computation will be something
that is a ubiquitous thing true of
everything out there in the world
now the question of is it growing
is it something where there is a process
where not only is it programmable but it
also
grows itself
it's it's an interesting question
whether that is a sensible way to do
things in other words rather than making
a mold to produce a particular thing or
having a producing device
that produces things have the things
grow themselves it's an interesting
question whether that's worthwhile and
when is it worthwhile to sort of grow
yourself
versus be imprinted be be stamped out be
templated in some way i'm not sure what
the answer that is my guess is that
there will be some things that are
convenient to grow but a lot of stuff
it's easier to have an external sort of
manufacturing of the thing and then to
have the thing itself be something which
no longer has the apparatus to
manufacture itself i mean if we look at
biology there's a certain amount of our
capabilities which are merely purely for
the replication of cells and things like
that for the creation of new material
and
if we ignored that if we said everything
is just is the way it is and it's all
been sort of stamped out
then perhaps we get to do certain things
more efficiently i'm not sure i mean
biology the idea that you will be able
to make a new cell when an old cell in
this particular position in space
uh you know fails or something that's
actually a pretty good idea and the
notion that you could have sort of a
self-healing technological system that
would grow another part of itself is not
such a terrible idea
but you know there are things like
airplanes for example i mean i think
back in the day a couple of hundred
years ago when people were thinking
about you know the expedition to the
moon
they imagined that i remember
when i was a kid at least seeing these
kind of uh sort of early science
fictionish books
where people would instead of having a a
bunch of horses pulling a horse-drawn
carriage that was going along on the
earth they would have a big flock of
geese or something that was hooked up to
their their spacecraft and they would be
being pulled to the moon by a collection
of geese
i'm clearly not the thing that's
actually going to work but one could
imagine that it would have been
interesting thing whether that had
developed actually i don't know
why did that not happen it's an
interesting history of technology
question
why didn't happen because people had
gliders long before the wright brothers
long before powered flight
people had gliders and they knew if you
were able to pull a glider along
fast enough its wings would get lift
and it would be able to to fly and so
the question is why did people not take
birds
and have them and hook them up to a
glider have a whole pack of a whole
flock of birds you hook them up to a
glider just like you put a harness on
horses and you have that flock of birds
pull your glider around and pull it fast
enough that you get lift on the wings my
guess is the reason is because birds
aren't powerful enough but maybe
i wonder whether people tried that i
don't know maybe nobody tried it maybe
it was uh uh maybe it was uh but
otherwise we could have had a technology
where you know back in the 1800s we
could have had people
uh doing kind of the um for
uh luxury travel
or for warfare or something having
something where you had the
bird-drawn plane so to speak flying
around
my guess is that the detailed dynamics
of that don't work out
and possibly possibly even
it's the big innovation that the wright
brothers had in making powered flight
in when was it
[Music]
1905 right
um
that that um or 19
around that
first decade of the of the 1900s but in
any case the the um
the thing that um
uh
was um
um
the the one of the big innovations was
being able to control the plane it's one
thing to get lift it's another to be
able to control it and not have it sort
of spiral around and and uh and sort of
crash into the ground and that
innovation came when powered flight also
came and that innovation might have been
needed to make a bird drawn glider work
so maybe it's a thing even for today but
it's sort of interesting that for
example drones of the like quadrocopters
and things like that they only became
practical when battery capacities
reached a certain point and when
computer speeds reached a certain point
where you could control the thing to be
make it a stable flying object and so on
so the the dynamics of when the bird
drawn airplane becomes possible i don't
know what the uh what the sort of break
points for that are but i have to say it
would be very stylish to have um
have some kind of geese drawn
thing and
particularly maybe the geese are hard to
train i don't know that's always a an
issue one of the mysterious things with
them
uh with different kinds of animals and
so on is um uh you know some are easy to
train some are not i know it was a very
kind of premium thing to have a zebra
drawn carriage because zebras were
notoriously difficult even though
they're very similar to horses they were
notoriously difficult to train to get
them to say yes you really are going to
walk in this direction rather than just
go off and do your own thing
um but uh in any case okay i think by
the time we've uh descended into um uh
uh
into talking about some
uh geese drawn aeroplanes maybe it might
be um
might be time to stop and this question
about making things out of organic
materials as i say
the organic materials tends to mean
things like amino acids and so on
whether the molecular scale computing
that we will do will use
that will piggyback on the particular
last three billion years of evolution
that life on earth has had i'm not sure
i i think it will be a little bit
bizarre and perhaps even disappointing
if we had to do that because i think
there are many historical artifacts in
the way that that was constructed that
we can probably do better than but
that's um
and then the question is
more to the to the point is whether
there is growable stuff whether it is
imprinted type stuff and actually as i
think about it there might be good
arguments for having some growable type
stuff that might look a lot more kind of
lifelike in a sense
than uh other things we're used to and i
would say in general that the idea that
we make engineering structures that kind
of look simpler than living systems that
is very much a feature of our ways of of
thinking about engineering that we
always want to be able to kind of
foresee what the outcome of the
engineering is going to be and so we end
up with these things that have a
somewhat simpler structure than this the
the possible structures that could exist
in nature or the possible structures
where you could pick any one of these
structures and you just select the one
that happens to work that can lead you
to much more complicated looking
structures where we're much less able to
foresee by doing sort of pure thought or
pure calculation what's going to happen
in that particular system
all right well i think we should wrap up
here
so uh
thanks for joining me and um
uh see you another time and please um
uh i think there's a mechanism for
sending in questions and topics
um beforehand but otherwise uh please
come friday afternoon
and uh
um ask whatever you want to ask
it's always interesting for me to
try and uh respond to these things and
uh
sometimes
well today i know there were a number of
explanations that i was able to give you
which i don't think i've ever expressed
before or really untangle those
explanations before so it's really
really great to have the the impetus to
do that
so well thanks very much see